for a player so accustomed to winning
novak djokovic now knows he's up against
an opponent determined to play hardball
the australian government has made it
clear that at no point was the world
number one guaranteed entry to the
country
in its legal submission it said
further still there is no suggestion
that the applicant had acute major
medical illness in december 2021 all he
has said is that he tested positive for
covert 19. that is not the same
the email from the department stated
that the applicant's responses to his
australian traveler declaration
indicated that he met the requirements
for quarantine free travel into
australia well the first thing that
needs to be uh verified is that you
actually hold a visa for entry
the conditions of entry really aren't
relevant at that particular stage when
you board your aircraft so at the end of
the day
if you're granted a visa it is at best
an invitation to present yourself at the
border and then be considered for entry
to australia so
a visa is no guarantee
djokovic claims to have tested positive
on december 16th but questions will no
doubt be raised in court in melbourne
about these images from that day and the
next in belgrade he was seen mixing
indoors with people and not wearing a
mask
meanwhile another rally has taken place
in the serbian capital in support of the
20-time grand slam winner
it's a huge day today it's the day we
will see the judge and it's the day when
we will finally get justice and also
hear the truth the whole world needs to
hear the truth we need to know what
happened finally we hope that the court
is not biased that they will reach the
right verdict and that novak will come
out of this as a winner as a free man
which is what he is
the defending australian open champion
is spending a fourth night at this
immigration detention center in
melbourne a city that endured
262 days of lockdown
with the federal election this year the
djokovic case has huge significance
outside of sport
tennis australia say they want to know
by tuesday for scheduling reasons if the
reigning champion will be able to play
the judge in this case has already
indicated he won't be rushed
ender brady sky news